i've been hearing a lot of rumors
that there's this new guy in town
more specifically this new man on the
street
he goes by the name of piers morgan so
does he have what it takes to make it in
prime time well let's see
president biden
vowed that he would unite the country
you must be thrilled with the way things
are going
not particularly
i think he's doing a good job wow i
think he has a better shot of uniting
his family maybe he should start with
his family before he starts with america
you know the big guy was somebody and i
got a feeling i know who that guy might
be what's the one thing you'd like biden
to do to unite america
get out of office just get out of the
way don't you think it's a tragedy that
you no longer have a king or queen in
this country and wouldn't you like maybe
someone like me to come back on the
throne
no thank you king in the castle king in
the castle you wouldn't like king pierce
the first
on a big throne maybe up there
yeah no no thank you no god please no no
president biden told vladimir putin to
knock it off do you reckon that will do
the trick
no
no come on man you think of one good
thing biden's done stayed awake
karma harris wants people to stand every
time she enters a room as if she's the
kind of american version of the queen of
england
what would you stand for carmela harris
ah no how do you feel about that
um i think it's pretty arrogant to be
honest i'm speaking i have i'm speaking
we in the uk gave meghan markle back
to the united states and in fact to
california and we're very grateful that
you took her off our hands
in return for the favor that you did us
who would you like to send
to the uk tom cruise tom cruise yeah why
no reason who's coming
who's coming with meghan markle
are you are you a fan yes i am why i
think she's relatable she gonna be fine
i know she did but
have you any idea who that guy is i've
no idea but i know he's not as famous as
you please
oops hashtag orgs have you any idea who
that is brett waters brett waters yeah
that's it he's got a big future in tv i
think yeah he does bread does yeah yeah
ross lost from friends and friends yes
that's how you think it is yeah this
totally makes sense it does not do you
reckon i can take him down
you know what i have no doubt he's tough
but i think you're going to bring him
down i think you're going to bring him
down i think you're right i think i'm
right about that i think i'm right if i
go down you're going with me
wrong again you think that it's time
that fox had more english accents
that would work you reckon 7 p.m maybe
7 works for me yeah it works for me yeah
do you think here's this planet has it
got a good ring to it it sounds real
good i'm thinking 7 p.m here's this
planet i'm piers and this is my planning
ah
almost had it down with the arm motion
i didn't quite get it here's working on
censored all right before we get to your
new show what did you find out when you
went out on the street it was cold and
we did that to you on purpose it was
freezing cold uh in fact i've got a
slight burst blood vessel from
marching the streets in freezing
temperatures so thank you
i discovered i'm hugely popular yeah i
was a bit of a shock um but they were
mainly brits actually circling yeah how
did you know how to pick out the british
people uh you could tell them a milo you
can the shoes it's the bad teeth
if you see shiny teeth coming you think
american if you see yellow fangs you
know the brits are in town you mentioned
something before we got on the air here
about the last segment we did about
america's misperceptions about who we
are as a country and you said you
thought that was coming from twitter
what did you mean by that well because
twitter is a phenomenon in which all
journalists love to partake in i love
twitter you love twitter but in reality
only 20 of the american population are
on twitter 80
never go near it or hear or read
anything on it and of the 20 that use it
in america
10 make 80 percent of the noise so 10 of
that 20 percent make 80
think about that and they skew mainly
sort of smartars woke
and they have all these powerful jobs in
the media and politics so then they're
warping our perceptions they are
complete i thought was fascinating the
the graphs you had there because they
are completely warping reality
they are talking about a country which
doesn't exist it doesn't exist and in
their minds it exists and maybe in new
york city but not in the rest of the
country so the question for the rest of
us is and this is what the premise of my
show actually is are we going to be
driven towards a mentality this ultra
woke canceled culture state of mind
which actually the vast majority of
people in america in the uk in australia
pretty much anywhere in the world
vehemently disagree with and i say no so
we're the majority yeah these other
people are insane but they're making
life crazy for the rest of us and it's
worse than that they're actually
wielding such an unhealthy power over
corporate america and and media you saw
what happened with disney you see it and
you see them being bullied mercilessly
all the time my message to corporate
america is be more like netflix and
spotify and less like disney because you
can't bow to the mob right be true to
yourself be true to your talent
understand what free speech actually
means free speech means that you
tolerate views you don't agree with it's
not about saying my view is the only
view and if you don't agree we're
cancelling you do it one more time i'm
peers
and this is my planet i'm pierce and
this
is my plan we'll see you on fox nation
thank you very much piers morgan hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else